hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear my little movie review series
so overall uh i've generally had pretty
good luck with most of the shutter
originals and shutter exclusives that
i've watched on there i will say that
the team at shutter really seemed to
have a really good handle on
uh curating really well like what
appears on their streaming service like
they have like a good variety of stuff
and they seem to like know
what horror fans want to watch
so pretty much like almost everything
that they acquire that they have a hand
in producing is at least worth watching
uh no i am actually not sponsored by
shutter it would be nice but you know
what i mean but um i've had them for a
really long time and i just think
they're a really really good streaming
service if you're a horror fan and
especially that doesn't you know
especially for the reasonable price i
mean really i think it's only like 50
something dollars a year and uh you know
it's just a really good deal they have
like a really good lot of good stuff on
there so uh on a very recent live stream
i can't remember if it was like a week
or two ago or something like that
somebody in the chat recommended the
2022 shutter original film revealer to
me
so i wrote it down and i was like okay
well i have not been keeping up with
shutter as much because i have so many
other streaming services too and you
know so i've been jumping back and forth
so i was kind of happy to get back into
like a new like shutter exclusive that i
could watch because i had kind of been
neglecting them a little bit so i will
say i mean the poster looks fantastic it
has that real 80s like new retro wave
kind of vibe that i love and i read the
one one sentence synopsis of it and it
sounded like a lot of fun so i was like
okay i'm game let's jump right in so
revealer is actually the feature film
debut of a guy named luke boyce now his
previous stuff i believe he made some
documentaries and he also made a kind of
widely praised short film uh called the
puka back in 2017. now that was actually
completely absolutely nothing to do
with the hulu into the dark like
original horror films puka from 2018 and
puka lives from 2020 both of which i've
talked about on this series at various
times it doesn't have anything to do
with that it just kind of happens that
it was uh called the same thing
so luke boyce also wrote this film
or co-wrote it rather his other two
writers on it were
a guy named michael
marici i guess is how you pronounce his
last name he's a comic author and a
novelist he's written like some star
wars fan like uh you know novels in that
canon and stuff like that probably best
known for stuff like burning fields like
that comic and roche limit which like a
sci-fi and also you got comic artist and
writer tim seeley uh probably best known
for hackslash and he also did revival so
again like a comic artist and writer so
this movie revealer it clearly has a
very very minuscule budget not sure
exactly what the budget was but it was
pretty small and it was shot uh largely
during the coveted lockdown i guess like
in the over the summer i believe of 2020
but i will say that it has like a very
ambitious premise for its extremely
limited locations and it's very very
small cast so i do actually like really
admire that so at the beginning of the
movie uh after this brief and sort of
strange little teaser prologue kind of
scene there's like a televangelist who
actually never appears again in the rest
of the movie i don't think and he seems
to be enduring some type of judgment or
something like that in this very narrow
hallway which is kind of lit with this
real hellish like red light
um so after we see that we get into the
story proper so uh cato uh ace i guess
is how you pronounce her last name uh
she plays angie who's kind of like this
wise ass you know no-nonsense stripper
um and she makes a living dancing in a
peep show booth in this kind of sleazy
adult bookstore which is called
revealers and this is actually set in
the 80s so it's set in 1987 in chicago
so she's one of the main characters now
angie's arch nemesis
is this girl named sally who's played by
shayna schruten now sally is like this
uptight bible thumper type she's got
like this really tragic like super
frizzy hair and those big like 80s
enormous like nerd glasses
and she heads this protest group
that has taken it upon themselves to
kind of uh you know hang out like they
sort of came out in front of this strip
joint essentially like this adult
bookstore and they just kind of wave
their signs all the time screeching at
anybody that sort of dares to enter this
den of iniquity that's gonna go in there
and like you know watch the ladies
within sort of shaking their little
sinful money makers there so yeah so
they like i said this is kind of like
their mission in life just to hang
outside and harass people that go into
this like adult bookstore so i actually
got really immediately like sucked into
this scenario because it gave me like
this whole satanic panic kind of energy
because i mean i like i remember what it
was like in 1987 in 1987 when you had
these kind of
real like sanctimonious kind of like
[ __ ] like hanging out in front
of strip joints and stuff like that i
mean i know they still do that nowadays
but it was kind of like more of a big
thing back then so i was just kind of
like oh yeah i remember this kind of
crap so angie the stripper uh she's
clearly done with this [ __ ] uh she's had
enough of these kind of like these
religious weirdos making her already
hard life like even more difficult
but uh she also does seem to enjoy kind
of verbally sparring with sally like
kind of going back and forth mostly
because it seems like it's really easy
to like offend her tender sensibility so
you know all you have to do is like
swear or like say something kind of like
sexually suggestive and she gets all
like upset about it which is like kind
of funny
so uh so there's some back and forth
between the two of them in the parking
lot and then angie goes into the
building where we're we're going to be
spending pretty much the rest of the
movie like i said this is very much a
bottle type of movie i guess where it's
just kind of essentially one location so
know that going in that it's just even
though the premise of it is like very
vast uh it's actually like pretty much
just one location so she gets in the
building and kind of shares some more
banter with the owner manager not really
sure if he owns the place or manages it
uh whose name is ray who's played by
bishop stevens
and uh then like she goes down to her
pete booth she's like i need to pick up
an extra shift you know like for some
extra money or whatever and there's some
foreshadowing about how the door of her
peep booth like always sticks and like
she always has to have rey to come in
there and kind of muscle it and it's
like really hard to open because there's
some kind of like thing with the
floorboard like sticking up which will
play into it later on so like i said
that's kind of like foreshadowing so
after that she kind of like goes to work
and you know she dances on her chair
there's kind of like a a dance sequence
with like these really gorgeous like
pink and blue like neon lights and all
this other kind of stuff and then you
see kind of like the you know the the
panting dudes that are coming in like
sticking their crumbly five dollar bills
like through the slot and she's like
performing for each one of them and the
music and this is great by the way which
i'll get back to in a minute but yeah
it's like really really good music in
this too so there's like kind of a cool
like dance sequence you know what i mean
but
not too long into the festivities uh
something rather dire seems to be
occurring outside of this adult
bookstore
so we just see like a very brief shot of
like sally is like outside she looking
very odd and also like very terrified
and she's kind of like uh you know
imposed against the sky and the sky is
just like turning orange and it's like
boiling with clouds and there's just
like lightning that doesn't really look
like it's all that natural uh and angie
meanwhile is inside and she's still in
the booth like waiting for the next
customer and she starts hearing
something that sounds really bad from us
like she hears like people banging and
screaming and like all this other kind
of stuff so she's like shouting to ray
like what the [ __ ] is going on out there
you know what i mean it sounds like
really bad and uh he doesn't answer her
so uh at one point like the protesters
who are all outside all try to like pile
into the bookstore and like through the
door you see that there's like some you
know
bad looking [ __ ] going on outside but
ray like forces them out like get the
[ __ ] out of here what are you doing um
so actually only sally manages to make
her way into the adult bookstore and she
hides in one of the booths which is like
adjoining aegis like it's right next to
it so then once everything has kind of
gone quiet a bit uh sally reveals that
you know she's talking to her through
the booth wall
that all hell has literally broken loose
outside uh in short end of the world is
at hand it's time to repent all this
other kind of stuff now of course angie
uh does not believe it at first because
who would um she's like hey if anything
apocalyptic is going on out there i'm
sure like the russians are responsible
because 80s but sally is like pretty
insistent about it no this is it like a
biblical end of the world it's happening
and she gets like super super
sanctimonious about it um she's certain
that she will eventually be raptured up
to heaven and angie you know her trampy
ass is gonna be judged and she's gonna
be left to suffer for eternity on the
hell that the earth will become so she's
kind of like sally's kind of like
rubbing it in a little bit it's like we
told you guys you're gonna happen but
it's like your liberal media would like
wouldn't
listen to us and all this other kind of
stuff but it's like pretty funny so
there was all that kind of stuff and
she's just like okay whatever but yeah
she's being a role snot about it like
she thinks she's gonna be all special
and rescued and stuff like that so this
is essentially the premise uh in a
nutshell yes the biblical apocalypse is
actually happening in 1987 and angie is
trapped in her peep show booth because
remember i said the door sticks and she
can't like get it open by herself and uh
not only that as if that wasn't bad
enough of being trapped in a peep [ __ ]
booth and it's the end of the world she
also has to listen to this insufferable
[ __ ] that's like just telling her what
a hoe she is like through the wall it's
like you know it's like her worst enemy
so i guess it kind of is hell on earth
from that uh point of view
but uh as the story goes on uh and the
these two like diametrically opposed
women
have to work together to you know first
make their way out of the booth and then
like try to get out of the place by
going there they start really going
through like the bootlegging tunnels i
know this is chicago so they're going
like through the bootlegging tunnels
like underneath the city like they have
to get down there and uh you know so
they have to kind of work together to do
that and they're also being like pursued
by the demon of judgment or whatever
asmodeus or whatever his name is and uh
so as that goes on
they actually start to
develop a mutual respect as they get to
know one another as people as more
things about them are revealed hence the
name revealer and realize that they're
not as different as they once believed
and they both have reasons for doing
what they do and that the choices that
they made now as i mentioned this is
very obviously a low budget film uh it
takes place pretty much entirely inside
an adult bookstore and in a series of
like underground brick tunnels which all
kind of look very similar to one another
and any hint as to the like epic end of
the world [ __ ] that's presumably going
on outside of the building comes almost
entirely from sound effects and from
sally's character who obviously is set
up as she's very very well versed in the
bible and particularly in the book of
revelation so she kind of knows what's
going on at any moment like like for
example it's like they hear the trumpet
she's like oh that's the third trumpet
and that means that the star wormwood is
falling to the earth and that means all
the water is poisoned now and all this
other kind of stuff so that's kind of so
she's kind of giving like a blow-by-blow
like as it goes because they don't
really show it so like i said you know
we don't see any of this stuff happening
because like i said it's very low budget
but
i actually really admire like the
filmmakers spirit in making a movie with
this like vast a scope and bringing it
down to a more intimate level i thought
that was like a really good idea
now there are some
cgi like worm snake type creatures uh
that that i guess are like you know
lesser demons or whatever and the women
have to fight them occasionally and the
demon like asmodeus or whatever he shows
up at the end and it's just basically
it's practical effects which is like a
guy in a pretty okay costume um but for
most of the movies runtime we're
basically just following angie and sally
as they're trying to come to terms with
what's happening like what's going on
outside and working together to get
themselves out of whatever kind of minor
scrapes like arise along the way like
while they're trying to get out from the
building and you know trying to figure
out where they're gonna go from here
like if this is indeed what's really
going on now i wouldn't necessarily call
this a horror comedy although it does
have humor in it and i will say that
it's like hard not to love a movie that
uses the phrase kuz bruce which made me
like laugh out loud and there was also
kind of i think angie at one point tells
him something like says something at 1.2
where he says yeah i punched you right
in your dusty [ __ ]
it's like that really made me laugh too
but yeah so there is humor in it but i
don't think it's not like overtly funny
like it's not like a horror comedy um
now there is some gore and violence but
not very much so don't go into this like
expecting some big gorfest because it's
not like there is a little bit of gore
but not a lot like a lot of it happens
like off-screen uh essentially this is
like
a buddy film or like a character study
but it has sort of like this cool retro
like apocalyptic veneer to it um so i
will say that given that it's really a
goddamn good thing that both of the lead
actors are great i mean both of the
women in this are dynamite they're
really really fantastic and i actually
got really really invested in their
characters and in their struggles and
like just all the conversations they
were having as more things about their
personality came out they were just
really really great um so i think that
really really helped like kind of
elevate this movie quite a bit obviously
i related more to angie because she's
more like what i'm like and you know and
at the beginning sally as she's supposed
to comes across as like this really
condescending like judgmental harpy who
really doesn't know anything about the
world but thinks she knows everything
and thinks she has everything figured
out and she can tell everybody else what
to do um so obviously she's like really
really uh irritating and like
insufferable at first but as the movie
goes on and more about her gets revealed
like why she is the way she is why she
has the beliefs that she has she also
ends up becoming sympathetic as well and
i actually did really buy into
the friendship that develops between the
two women as they're trying to get out
of this situation so i'm actually not
really sure if two lesser actors
could have carried this film because so
much of the success of this film and the
premise of it is resting on their
shoulders because like i said there's
not a lot of special effects there's not
a lot of locations you don't see a lot
of the stuff it's mostly just on them
like almost all the time and i think
they really kind of hit it out of the
park so if the movie works it's because
of those two now obviously revealer
isn't going to be for everybody i've
seen some pretty uh scathing and
negative reviews of it uh not gonna lie
but i've also seen some pretty rapturous
ones as well yes that what pun was very
much intended but uh yeah but i have
seen some reviews and people like really
really hated it so i think this is gonna
be one that's be like sort of divisive i
actually really enjoyed this quite a bit
though uh it was very noticeably kind of
hemmed in limited by its tiny tiny
budget uh the pacing sagged in place
it's not a long movie i think it's only
hour 26 minutes something like that but
there was like a little sag and like i
said um because a lot of it takes place
in these tunnels underneath so there's
not you know the character really has to
carry it because the scenery isn't
really you know it doesn't really uh
differ all that much like from scene to
scene uh and some of the special effects
looked a little bit cheesy like the worm
uh you know the worm snake things like
the cgi was a little bit cheesy the d's
the demon like outfit was a little bit
cheesy and you could tell like i said
you could tell it was a low budget but i
mean the score and the music when much
of it was actually done by a gunship was
[ __ ] awesome i really really liked
the music for this i really liked the
80s neon look of it like with the
saturated light that looked really cool
i always loved that kind of look uh and
the two leads were just stellar i mean i
really got into their characters they
really sold it and i think that their
sort of journey toward mutual
understanding seemed very genuine and
heartfelt now some of the dialogue was a
little bit too like on the nose i felt
like but i don't know it was just like i
said it was so genuine that it really
didn't bother me all that much um now i
thought the end was a little bit
ambiguous but i didn't really mind that
all that much i mean it is the end of
the world after all so it's not like you
know two young women can actually win
against like the end of like the
biblical apocalypse so you know so i
kind of like that they left it
open-ended oh i'll also add that if you
are gonna watch this like i said it's on
shutter um keep watching at least like
through the start of the credits because
the movie actually i'm assuming like
using cgi like opens up and shows more
of what happened in the world outside
the bookstore like this whole like uh
you know i don't want to give it away
but you know what i mean but just like
keep watching it because it does kind of
open it up um i've also heard that you
know because two of the writers are you
know known for their work in comics so
i've heard that there's and i don't
think it's out yet but i think there's
going to be like a sequel comic that
will carry on the story of the two women
like after the end of the world and i
think that's actually a great idea
because this type of concept like you
can get away with it in this tim because
it's like i said it's just like a buddy
film or a character study but this
concept if you're gonna keep going with
it it probably needs to be expanded into
a medium where there aren't any
budgetary constraints so i think that's
a great idea if they're gonna like you
know continue it in that format so i
mean if you like kind of small scale
apocalyptic buddy horror that has kind
of like some new wave flair i guess and
also like great music then you know give
this one a spin you might really like it
don't expect like this big epic showdown
between good and evil or anything like
that i think this is more just like kind
of a relax and hang out kind of movie
just get into the characters and you
know their interactions and stuff like
that because that's kind of what is the
backbone of this movie and let me know
if you've seen it because i know like
one of you guys um you know recommended
it so i'd be curious to know like what
what everybody thought about this one
because like i said i feel like this
one's kind of divisive like at least
from the reviews that i've seen people
either seem to really really like it or
really really hate it but you know i
thought it was really really good for
the budget you know the limitations that
they had i think they did like a really
good job and like i really did like the
concept overall so let me know what you
think about it in the comments if you've
watched it and that will do it for this
flickers of fear i will see you guys
again on the next one
bye